you're going to see sides of her in this
series that you've never seen before are
you ready to find out everything we know
about Wednesday Adams like did you know
Tim Burton hand-picked the entire cast
or that Jenna Ortega performed her own
stunts and got to work with the OG
Wednesday Christina Ricci I know the
suspense is killing you number one how
many times did you see Wednesday blink
there are little Wednesday mannerisms
sprinkled throughout Jenna's performance
that only super Keen eyes would be able
to see it's funny I think my posture has
improved immensely since working on that
job her posture was always perfect and
her arms and hands stay pretty
stationary most of the time at some
point during the first couple weeks of
shooting I did a take where I did not
blink at all Tim Burton loved that take
so he and Jenna decided that it would be
one of Wednesday's weird mannerisms she
didn't even know she was doing it half
the time it just sort of happened every
time she would reset for a take I would
drop all the muscles in my face and Tim
really liked the Kubrick stare where I
stared through my eyebrows number two
Jenna was in a non Stop Cycle of work
for eight months straight we're talking
a minimum of 12 hour work days I would
wake up around 4 30 I would be picked up
around
5 20 ish by 6am she's in wardrobe by 6
30 she's inherent makeup and by 8 AM
she's on set you would do 12-hour days
we would have rolling lunches so we just
eat when we could then in the evening by
around six o'clock she's in stunt
rehearsal because on top of all this
she's doing her own stunts and fight
sequences more on this later and then I
might have a cello lesson and then I go
home that was my day that was my life
for eight months in Romania number three
the shoot days were extra long for a
reason Tim Burton and Jenna Ortega
wanted to do as many different takes as
possible to really nail down Wednesday's
characterization for every single scene
and every single one of these takes were
on camera we're hoping to see an
extended edition with all the bloopers
looking at you Tim number four her hair
was one of the most important factors
everyone knows Wednesday Adams as the
girl with the signature long dark braids
but it was important to Tim Burton to
establish some sort of difference
between who she was then and who she is
now they did a lot of experimentation
with different wigs and clips but in the
end Jenna Ortega being as dedicated as
she is offered up something invaluable I
said hey maybe maybe just cut my actual
hair she was and they did and then he
loved it and that was something that
that we married and we stuck to number
five there's major sword fighting and
fencing going on in this show one of the
things that makes Jenna Ortega so
incredible is the dedication she gives
to her work she spent so many hours
training to perfect her fencing and
sword fighting skills so she could
perform her own stunts there's really
important physical aspects like that
like the fencing that I knew that I
wanted to do myself and and have
ownership of number six 20 minutes of
winging it the audition process was over
Zoom as Jenna was in New Zealand filming
X she hadn't slept in 24 hours and
described her audition process as being
tired enough to wing it the audition
only took 20 minutes soon after she had
to pack up and moved to Romania for
eight months when you're approached with
a character like this and a director
like this and a story like this it's
very compelling you don't know when
you're going to get the opportunity to
do something like that again I knew that
I just had to take it number seven every
single detail was intentional when
creating Wednesday's look no detail was
too small the show's creators had a lot
to say about her look everything about
her look was intentional Wednesday's
shoes for example our next level every
teenage girl in the world is going to
have serious shoe Envy once they see
them when you first see Wednesday she's
in her iconic white collared black dress
outfit but then as The Show Goes On Her
Style evolves they always wanted her to
stand out from the crowd in some way
number eight one of the most important
factors of the show's look Romania is
not a location that you'll often see in
the media so capturing that grandiose
Eastern European Vibe was a huge
inspiration for both the cast and crew I
did send a photograph of my myself in my
office to my agent and said is this what
your office looks like number nine there
are a lot of subtleties to Jenna
Ortega's performance Wednesday's
somebody that I always was compared to
my entire life though the show Runners
found her to be a perfect fit for the
character she was nervous to portray her
because she wanted so badly to do the
character Justice I went to fencing
lessons twice a week
I went to cello lessons twice a week
everywhere she went she would walk like
Wednesday she thought people would think
she was insane with how much she was
putting into nailing down the character
I wanted her to be specific and certain
and assertive number 10. Tim Burton had
a very specific vision for Wednesday
according to Jenna he was one of the
most detail-oriented directors she'd
ever worked with the thing that makes
Tim a great visual director is that he
has an amazing sense of color and style
he liked to have a say in how every shot
was framed and even the type of lens
used on the camera because he kind of
liked when they were wide and a bit
disoriented he designed and brought to
life every single character with
sketches goth comes to him very
naturally and Tim designed what the
Monster looks like in the show number 11
what kind of show would this be without
the appearance of the original Wednesday
Addams Christina Ricci joins the cast as
Marilyn Thornhill a teacher at Nevermore
Academy it is scary it's a lot of
pressure and you you want to do justice
to someone like her you would think that
Jenna and Christina would be having some
pretty intense conversations about the
character they've both portrayed right
the strange thing is we never talked
about her being Wednesday once there was
only one time on the last day of
shooting that Jenna made a reference to
Christina's version of Wednesday they
both had an understanding and an
acceptance that their versions were
going to be different number 12. did you
know Jenna always wanted to star in a
silent film it is a hard thing to play
with an expressionless character the
origin of most of Wednesday's mannerisms
and movements came from the idea of it
being shot like a silent film I felt
like that really encouraged mannerisms
or kind of balance the aspects of
surrealism and realism in the film Tim
Burton really connected with the idea as
well given the fact that the way Jenna
conveyed emotion most of the time was
silently through her Expressions because
they can be very theatrical and dramatic
and intense and that is what Adam's
family is number 13 Wednesday was
originally a Latina character in The
Addams Family Comics one of the most
important parts of this role for Jenna
Ortega was getting to represent
Wednesday as a Latina because it has
never been done before anytime that I
have an opportunity to represent my
community I want that to be seen another
way Tim Burton wanted to make this known
was by exemplifying the fact that the
Addams Family participates in Dia de los
Muertos I was just in the living room
more seating for a year-long Dia de los
Muertos number 14. the entire town was
built from the ground up coupled with
the extraordinary setting of Romania the
set of the show was like a character in
itself Gwendolyn Christie talks about
her experience at New York Comic-Con
what I loved was that we filmed in
Romania so you have Landscapes that had
not been seen before it's almost like
looking at things with quite a fresh
pair of eyes on an epic scale and much
of what you see is real this team really
went all out they built a town and used
locations and there's an awful lot of
authenticity to bring that very specific
culture to life number 15 can you
imagine getting an email from Tim Burton
Jenna was busy filming the horror movie
X as conversations about Wednesdays
started to come up at Netflix Tim Burton
was the one who thought about her for
the role as he was a fan of her work so
he sent her an email asking if they
could meet I kind of felt like I was
being pranked or something naturally
everyone fell in love with her
performance right away because I'm very
dry and I don't think people can tell
when I'm being serious or when I'm being
sarcastic with Tim Burton behind the
show along with his incredible
hand-picked cast and crew Wednesday is
an iconic piece of media in the making
with your favorite behind the scenes
moment